[Musique]
il je
bonjour pascal légitimus car
on va parler évidemment de mots de jeu
de mots on va parler de cette alfa
bêtisier c'est le livre que vous avez
publié mais il ya peut-être un bout sur
le cas où on pourrait s'arrêter d'abord
parce que au fond je ne sais pas si
c'est une gestion peut-être qu'on vous a
beaucoup pesé mais qui m'intéresse c'est
cdj thymus c'est votre nom légitime ou
celui qui légitiment un kéké pas du tout
absolument qu'elle nous de votre mise
vous savez d'où ça vient c'était
philippe bouvard qui croyais que c'était
un pseudonyme à l'époque quand j'étais
au théâtre de bouvard et je dis non non
c'est mon vrai nom et encore il ya une
suite c'est légitimus de lac léman
lierre de bois dormant de courtemanche
et vicomte de bragelonne on va couper
tout ça et oui ce étude est d origine
ethiopian d'après ce que nous père m'a
dit puisqu'on a engagé la musique
normalement qui à la maison dans un
tiroir
succinctement c'était au xviie siècle au
xviiie siècle le roi donc d'ethiopie
meurent de ce mariage là il y avait deux
enfants le chambellan le premier
ministre se marier avec la reine et le
chambellan ne veut pas des deux enfants
donc les mets en esclavage sur la côte
ouest les enfants se sont donné un nom
comme qu'ils étaient les enfants
légitimes du royaume de cricket avant
légitime à faux et à chaque fois qu'un
esclave donc apparaît on lui donne un
nom qui correspond à un métier à laure
charpentier tout ça et là donc c'était
un surnom qui voulait dire qu'ils
étaient les enfants légitimes de
reynolds et la lignée qu'à continuer
c'est le négus hailé sélassié donc j'ai
des origines éthiopienne via l'afrique
et arménienne par ma mère quand même
ridley bizarrement la langue éthiopienne
et arméniennes ont des points communs et
bizarrement
l'arménie et l'ethiopie ce sont des deux
premiers peuples chrétiens
donc je suis issu d'un truc un peu
bizarre il n'y a pas beaucoup souffert
non mais c'est vrai que j'ai quand j'ai
appris ça il ya trente ans j'ai dit ah
oui d'accord et donc la cia s'en est
mêlée parce qu'en même temps la famille
voulait un peu
légitime et si je puis dire cette
origine et la cia via je suis plus
tranquille ces bons qui m'a raconté sa
vie moi vous vous calmez c'est bon on
est comme ça il n'y a pas besoin de
retrouver les racines de donc ça prouve
que ça lui était vrai d'accord et alors
évidemment il ya sous volet l'ailé les
acteurs les comédiens les humoristes
monde est-ce qu'on est légitime ou
est-ce qu'on est utiles c'est une
question vous est posée de temps en
temps ouais je pense que j'ai fait ce
métier là au départ par par carence
affective comme souvent c'est qu'on a
envie d'être aimé donc on fait un métier
où on est tout seul où on partage des
choses avec des camarades et puis les
gens vous aiment ensuite je les fais
parce que c'est par passion à partir de
40 ans je me suis dit
j'ai envie d'être dans la transmission
donc il ya trois étapes oui c'est vrai
qu'on va dire si vous avez travaillé
pour vous vous avez travaillé en groupe
vous avez travaillé aussi beaucoup pour
les autres avec notamment des mises en
scène
et je compte de cette question de
l'utilité parce que on a l'impression
mais je sais pas si c'est l'impression
que que le que les artistes eux-mêmes
d'être un peu différent des autres est
ce que est ce que c'est vous qui avez
cet impressionnant ou est ce que c'est
le public qui vous renvoie cette image
je pense que c'est le public qui nous
renvoie qui nous terrifie parce que moi
j'essaie d'être simple de vivre
normalement évidemment on a un statut
médiatisée de riz qu'on est toujours en
lumière
mais c'est vrai que quand je prends
l'avion souvent je passe ma vie dans les
cockpits partie les commandes bord ont
toujours envie de côtoyer un peu la
lumière donc et quand on va dans un
restaurant bien évidemment il ya un
tapis rouge on vous aime donc on leur a
fait du bien ces gens-là nom qui nous le
renvoie gentiment donc on donne une
super de table on a des avantages des
avantages en nature mais je pense que
c'est de l'amour il donc je sais pas et
est ce que
l'expression de ça est-ce que vous non
pas d'être toujours en représentation
justement ça s'est un peu c'est un peu
fatigant c'est fatigant à un ton qui
fait rire
a pas très longtemps j'étais aux
toilettes d'un hôtel parce que j'avais
un rendez vous dans un salon de thé de
l'hôtel professionnels dont je vais aux
toilettes donc les pissotières pourra
donc je me tiens debout je fais mes
affaires il ya un gars qui se met à côté
de moi piqué main que au nom de dieu et
puis tout en faisant ses affaires il
sort son portable il tient donc son
morceau d'un côté et il voulait que je
dis mais qu'est ce que tu fais
évidemment photo j m on peut terminer
d'uriné tranquille
et oem et vous allez partir je dis bah
on fait enfin voilà donc un moment donné
c'est compliqué alors il ya des gens qui
sont compréhensifs et d'autres qui sont
sympathiques et qu'ils comprennent
qu'ils ont là aussi une vie privée on
est nos yeux par endroits mais ça va je
me plains pas on leur appartient peut
quoi vous leur appartenait un peu les
gens sont et moi ils ont le sentiment ce
sentiment là comme les gens sont aimants
dans les deux sens du premier s'épanouit
vous n'êtes pas des pianos
gentil papa m'a pascal place d'un
clochard va tout va bien oui bon on va
pas vous plaindre parce que de toute
façon ça a commencé très tôt chez vous
dites déjà ou lycéens vous étiez vous y
du théâtre la jeune j'ai commencé à
l'âge de 10 ans c'est marthe mercadier
qui a produit une comédie musicale pour
enfants qui s'intitule à l'époque hasard
ou synchronicité la planète inconnue il
jouait au théâtre de l'athénée donc tous
les jeudis après midi dès samedi après
midi avec eric métayer on avait quoi 10
ans il avait 12 et ensuite j'ai continué
j'ai créé un club théâtre au lycée
claude-bernard avec daniel schick après
j'ai fait des doublages de films des
émissions pour enfants plein de choses
dont vous avez toujours voulu faire ça
quand ouais j'ai fait même clown dans
les hôpitaux à l'âge de 19 ans j'ai
toujours été passionné par le fait que
les gens me regardaient parce que moi
j'étais en carence affective ce que moi
j'ai perdu ma mère à ces jeunes quand
j'étais petit j'avais une petite maladie
des os donc on a mis dans un hôpital
pendant deux ans donc j'étais assez
assez mutique assez introverti et c'est
mon père qui a eu l'intelligence de me
faire faire du théâtre et ça m'a
tellement plus en plus si on est payé
bah tant mieux cela dit alors les vôtres
du jeu de mail était elle était dans le
métier de costumière votre père était
enfin vous est ce qu'on appelait
autrefois la un enfant de la balle
et est ce que ça change des choses et
comment ils vont regarder que vous étiez
petit donc c'est votre père qui vous a
un peu poussé à ça parce que souvent les
dents les autres familles quand
quelqu'un dit et je voudrais devenir
comédien ou acteurs ou artistes les gens
regardent la poussée c'était
psychanalytique c'était pour me sortir
de mon mutisme donc c'était plutôt un
remède mais il pensait pas qu'elle a
plus tard je deviendrai acteurs mais
quand il a vu que je commençais
à de vrais d'une bonne manière il était
plutôt fier parce qu'en fait je suis le
seul de la famille qui fait ce mythe est
là mon frère est ingénieur j'ai une
soeur aussi qu'est dans le bios et une
autre qui dans le milieu associatif
donc forcément il était fier d'avoir son
fils qui prolonge un peu lui n'a pas
fait complètement c'est à dire qu'il a
beaucoup travaillé mais n'a jamais été
connu donc voilà que moi ça me permet
aussi de dd ma famille financièrement
alors c'était plutôt agréable d'inverser
les tendances
affective et puis sans mauvais jeu de
mots pour lui c'était pas un sou dans
l'inconnu quoi
pourrait poser une question à la jacques
chancel pascal légitimus
c'est vous qui avez choisi l'humour
aussi humour il vous a choisi c'est moi
qui ai choisi d'humour parce que mon
départ je n'ai pas spécialement formatés
pour faire rire j'étais plutôt un enfant
grave mais je me suis rendu compte que
de faire rire mes camarades ça ça
permettait d'entrer dans un cercle voilà
deux d'appartenir insectes moi j'ai subi
le racisme étant jeune donc on me
mettais à part j'étais différent comme
j'ai la couleur entre deux chaises
andrée lessard pour un arabe un
brésilien mais j'arrête parce que
j'étais un métis un métissage donc
l'humour m'a quand même bien sauvé donc
je continue oui il faut savoir faire
rire pour désamorcer un peu j'avais des
clubs pas que jouer de la guitare qui va
égaler fille moi je faisais rire voilà
alors il ya eu le petit théâtre de
bouvard c'est là où vous savez donner
votre nom ces boîtiers
avec avec
les besoins tous mes camarades dit
bourdon laval évidemment avec des autres
vous avez commencé de 4 enfin avec les
inconnus attend à 3 c'est important de
cette seule fin d'être d'avoir le regard
des autres devra peut-être la protection
des autres c'est pas seulement ça c'est
que moi je suis un homme de troupe
j'aime bien partager ils ont bien joué
avec moi tout seul j'ai fait deux seuls
en scène vous l'avez ces jaloux parce
que j'avais des choses à dire personnels
qui étaient en dehors de la dynamique
des inconnus j'avoue que des deux seules
ces faut être courageux mais j'adore mon
esprit de troupe répéter une pièce de
théâtre partager travailler avec
échanges et j'adore ça et c'est
différent quand wade se vous avez été
aussi deux avec mathilda may
je vais avec michèle bernier dans une
ivresse oui je fais quelque chose mais
mais ça c'est du terme c'est plus du
temps c'est des exercices différents
d'être à trois avec des inconnus seul
dans les domaines bonne chose d'être
dans une pièce du théâtre on a un regard
quand on est seul on prend des risques
on sait pas mais on est tout seul
dieu il a mis voilà il a créé tous en
sept jours moi je crée un spectacle j'ai
pas du lin mais je crée un spectacle ça
me prend un an donc c'est compliqué et
quand on est plusieurs il ya un écho un
regard
on est on est sur la bonne route des
cons il ya une divergence
le regard de l'autre c'est important et
puis si on si on a deux sur trois qui
rigole ça faisait déjà partie 1 à 3 sur
3 insérez emballé c'est pesé allez hop
on est on est un peu protégés au faux
bond ou comme une famille mais c'est que
les autres vous demande aussi votre
regard bien sûr en fait les inconnus
c'est une famille y voilà on est trois
frères trois demi-frères mais c'est une
famille certes on est encore pas ton
cellule a pas très longtemps on
s'appelle les uns les autres
bernard est venu chez moi on fait des
brunchs fabula non on est vraiment des
amis en dehors du de l'artistique alors
il ya toujours cette demande comment est
ce que vous revenez sur scène ya
toujours des problèmes bernard est
conforme et à l'air un peu plus
réticents que d'un tgv il est hélas vous
pas ce que lui dit au fond c'est un peu
mal entendu je méritais pas ce succès
presque y est presque il ya presque ça
chez lui s'excuser un peu mais ça c'est
bernard qui est toujours un peu
introverti mais bon ça va il a du talent
il peut pas s'excuser de dette ce qui
n'est quand même pas qu'ils l'assument
mais c'est un type formidable moi j'aime
beaucoup paillasson film qui va sortir
la presque mais avec alexandre jollien
non en fait tous les trois on est on est
différent mais complémentaire
il ya complémentaires et je suis le mans
terre le flécher pas qui c'est
mais souvent nous dit je suis le tiers
des inconnus
nous avons un adn commun ouais et puis
il ya de bien quand même
formidable succès et puis cette
formidable il ya une nostalgie de tout
le monde ces nostalgiques vous l'êtes
vous l'expliquez comment
évidemment l'on l'envi du retour de sa
bs que parfois on dit c'est un humour
qu'on pourrait plus faire aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous en
pensez de son je pense qu'on peut rire
de tout mais ça dépend de la manière
qu'il est vrai qu'il ya certains sketchs
que nous avons eues fait il ya très
longtemps les mêmes aujourd'hui ça
serait compliqué parce que à l'époque
dans les chaînes de télé on recevait des
lettres des milliers de lettres oui les
gens réseaux sociaux qu'un de gens qui
étaient mécontents moi j'ai reçu une
lettre au théâtre de bouvard qui disait
à l'époque j'étais avec smaïn et donc
d'origine algérienne qui disait c'est
quoi ce et ce big o qui salissent
notre télévision à 19h45 donc quelqu'un
m'a passé cette lettre le garder parce
que je croise symboliquement c'est
important mais
des lettres comme ça on ne ressemblait
des milliers même sur la religion des
gens qui étaient mécontents de brefs
aujourd'hui c'est en direct donc les
décideurs prennent en compte ils ont
peur la vie des gens et donc forcément
et puis y'a des gens qui s'expriment
directement puis donc c'est compliqué
c'est très compliqué donc fait je pense
que le paquet cadeau doit être un peu
plus sophistiqué pour émettre un sujet
donc parce que je crois que c'est didier
qui dumont pourrait reprendre des
sketches qu'on a fait et puis d'autres
qu'on d'écrire et peut-être de nouveaux
crédits devions revenir sur scène je
pense qu'on prendrait des anciens si qsi
les gens voudront les tubes bien sûr si
michel fugain ne chante pas c'est un
beau roman on est déçu
on prendrait des anciens sketches et on
remanierait à la sauce moderne avec donc
des choses contemporaines donc ça ferait
un peu de nouveau et pour décrire et
peut-être trois sketches nouveau mais
c'est pas d'actualité pour l'instant
c'est plutôt un tuto film c'est plutôt
un film en ligne de mire qu'on risque de
tourner
avec un metteur en scène qui nous
propose ne se serait pas vu l'exclusion
c'est ça qui est différent et qui était
plutôt original et ça nous a plu en fait
ce qui était sympathique c'est qu'on a
dit oui sans se concerter donc tous les
trois on a tous les trojans on sait qu à
gueuler sur la même énergie se concerter
pour ça que on a dit oui c'est que ça
nous a plu bref donc c'est prévu pour
après on append consignes en bas de la
page donc on dit rien elle l'a la
notoriété que vous a donné évidemment
les inconnus ont été formidables parce
que c'est un accélérateur de carrière
est-ce que parfois vous a aussi
emprisonnée oui parce que de temps en
temps il ya des gens qui pouvaient dire
oui mais ils sont pas libres oui mais
ils sont à trois oui me font à trois
têtes qui vont maintenant c'est plus que
c'est plus qu'à parce que le jeu didier
il travaille différemment bernard aussi
de moi j'ai des projets donc en fait il
ya eu le plus besoin le pot commun est
pas prêt ce sont des voiliers des
électrons libres
et puis qui reviennent et puis on fait
des allers retours comme ça mais il ya
aussi le
l'image enfin kaki et qui est collé ou
l'étiquette qu'on colle
non bien sûr mais c'est vrai que parfois
on a envie de faire afin qu'enfin ils
avaient se souvenir des belles choses
face elle qui avait changé sacré vous
avez fait crimes en série vous à la télé
qu'ils étaient des choses très très
différente c'est parfois des étiquettes
difficile à décoller alors c'est j'ai vu
qu'il m'avait dit ça copain qui m'a dit
pascal si tu fais quelque chose et que
c'est de la qualité les gens aimeront
quoi qu'il en coûte si c'est de la merde
les gens dire ouais c'est moins bien
donc en fait notre but et on est
condamné à faire de la qualité donc les
choix que nous faisons ils sont
spécifiques et sont bien choisis ton
camp bernard a choisi son son rôle
j'avais été choisi par zabou pour faire
et le film se souvenir des belles choses
dans le scénario était géniale crimes en
série on m'a dit mais déjà pascal tu vas
pas faire un truc de de profileurs
cédera c'est un drame toi tu es une
étiquette de comédie si c'est bien je le
fais c'est pas bien je le fais pas il se
trouve que c'était génial en fait c'est
pas le public qui est qui collent les
étiquettes c'est souvent le bleu le
milieu qui se dit et le public va pas
aimer rang 1 c'est vrai qu'il ya des
gens il ya des intermédiaires qui sont
une prétention de alors que ce sont pas
des artistes sont plutôt des financiers
qui regarde en bas de la ve voilà bon
combien ça va coûter échos mais ça va
nous rapporter alors que c'est plus
qu'une fois que c'est sarkozy qui disait
ça y'a pas longtemps
c'est pas l'argent qui fait le projet
c'est le projet qui fait l'argent
j'ai tout dit au revoir sa ligne
vous avez travaillez beaucoup avec des
autres vous le disiez il ya la
transmission réussie beaucoup travaillé
pour les autres j'ai mis en scène
beaucoup de jeunes d'humoristes j'ai
fait à l'époque j'ai mis en scène
anthony kavanagh stéphane rousseau
arnaud gidoin claire jazz
laurent ruquier j'ai fait jouer parce
que ce sont des parts à j'adore faire ça
et j'aime bien me mettre au service des
autres jeux peut disparaître mettre mon
ego de côté et m et j'adore travailler
construire et puissant actuellement je
suis professeur de professeurs un bien
grand mot mais je suis parent est prof
de dans l'école de cinéma les troisièmes
donc il ya il encourt pas très loin donc
j'ai trente deux gamins entre 19 et 25
ans et je leur transmets des choses je
suis des master classes et on monte un
spectacle sur le thème peut-on rire de
tout voyez donc je suis un peu partout
mais j'aime bien j'adore ça il faut je
suis aussi pour terminer des stages dans
des entreprises qu'il ya des gens qui
ont besoin savent pas comment voilà
transmettre exprimer les choses j'arrive
bien à trouver les solutions ça c'est
mon truc donc je continue et puis c'est
un plaisir où il tance m quelque chose
et puis de vous de faire de faire
acquérir des gens voilà le succès c'est
quoi c'est de transmettre et de mettre
en transe allez mes 30 ans c'est bien
on va venir vite
on va jouer des mots b
c'est quoi la mise en scène justement
quand quelqu un rival qu'un spectacle
tout écrit c'est quoi c'est le regard de
l'autre justement c'est ça sent les
moyens pour que l'artiste arrive à son
but i de plus
performant possible des fois ils
s'égarent des fois c'est pas bien écrits
ou alors il ya une belle idée mais les
pas développé il ya aussi un jeu de
lumière il ya aussi un décorum il ya
beaucoup de choses en fait c'est un
regard extérieur et quand on est dans le
coeur du maelström on a du mal à mais
moi j'ai besoin d'avoir un oeil
extérieur pour les autres ça marche bien
mais pour moi même des fois j'arrive pas
et c'est normal donc j'ai ce regard là
j'ai ce recul et j'arrive à pour
terminer pour scinder mais on va dire
mon style en une phrase j'ai le sens de
l'harmonie en tout vous donner n'importe
quoi dès que ces déséquilibres et je
peux connaître ouais c'est mon truc qui
ça vient d'où ça vous savez je sais pas
c'est la seule qualité que je peux
m'octroyer ces gens je vois que
n'importe quoi une affiche une personne
et je peux dire ah ah ah ah lui valut de
mort c'est maintenant elle est pas bien
elle c'est un pervers narcissique
à l'affût rien ses parfums la couleur
affichée comme ça
je faisais instable j'entendais ce
passage fut des master classes et que je
peux parce que ce don là bas je ça me
permet de voilà de diffuser des des
pleins de gens à aider ces prétentieux
mais d'accompagner c'est plus juste il
ya un thème qui est que c'est cher et
c'est celui de la différence vous avez
ces travaux la phrase dans les trois
frères quand je dis il faut cultiver la
différence ils n'ont pas l'indifférence
avec laquelle j'ai dit bien sûr mais
c'est important moi je les subis moi
même donc comment peut-on reprocher à
quelqu'un ce qu'il n'a pas choisi d'être
est ce qu'il est on choisit pas d'être
au mondial même si le gêner dans une
minute chose sexuelle attention un
clavier ça n'existe pas ça on choisit
pas des pouvoirs arabes juifs handicapés
aveugle on ne choisit pas il ya un lien
ce qu est ce qu elle fait christophe
khider qui est oui un homme de petite
taille on dit comme ça maintenant il est
verticalement concentré
oui on a fait un sketch sur sera pour la
mecque
je dis que c'est un
un inconnu lui dimanche à l'inconnu
c'est ça c'est ça et cet essai est un
thème qui est important aujourd'hui
parce que oui oui s'estompe ici tu as du
mal parfois respecter les différences
justement m et ça s'estompe parce que
la france se mélangent les genres je me
voyez bien de campagne électorale qui a
des joueurs pour qui sait plus où il
implique est d'admettre ça il faut quand
même prendre conscience que la france a
des racines profondément rassise hante
il en fait on a peur du voisin de palier
on a peur du dugas du village d'à côté
on a peur de ce qu'on ne connaît pas en
fait c'est pas le racisme du nom s'est
fait mal c'est la lettre que vous aviez
reçu là c'est pas ça la ramenons les on
dit ça on dit sale les seules choses
sales arabes sale juif salle niakoués
l'ex de tes propres moi c'est pareil on
dit léon nissan noire je pas noir déjà
ça ça c'est noir et je me suis lavé ce
matin
mais ce qui est bizarre c'est que on
rajoute l'adjectif salle alors quand on
dit sale blanc c'est moins agressif
alors que le blanc c'est ce qu'ils
s'allient plus c'est vrai
je vous laisse réfléchir la 12è dans ce
type et nous parler d'eux après on va
vous dire aux livres mais d'une je me
suis quelqu'un qui disait comme ça vous
étés je suis un blanc pour les douars et
un noir pour les blancs c'est ça c'est
un peu ce qui vous arrive et ça je dédie
aussi dans mon spectacle ouvriers de mai
c'est à dire que quand j'allais chez les
parce que moi je suis pas
je suis café au lait chicorée donc c'est
ce que disait il ya ce à quoi
les gens du fond
mais donc quand j'allais chez les worms
et met en tête est trop haute et et
blanc toi quand j'allais chez les blancs
bêlante était noir mais non je
l'aï assez compliqué c'est compliqué
donc l'humour bas permis justement doit
y faire accepter tel que je suis on aime
mon âme j'espère où ma moustache mais
pas l'apparence on s'en fout de
l'apparence ou de bord alors on va
parvenir cette alfa bêtisier des voyages
en terme inconnu c'est reggie sous titre
aussi alors c'est elle
la règle est simple vous prenez un move
rajouter une lettre et ça ne change
c'est un bon alors c'est un mot qui
n'existe pas dans le dictionnaire normal
mais change le bout alors
alors c'est un jeu auquel on peut jouer
c'est très bien parce que on peut jouer
on peut on peut aussi donner des
définitions puis demandait aux gens qu
est ce que ça veut dire par exemple je
n'ai noté de quelques-unes le par écoute
un hebdomadaire par exemple j'aime et
j'ai bien aimé le tour moderne
et ben et ben c'est un instinct chamoux
qu'on n'utilise qu'une fois par semaine
mon célibat tard c'est à oui s'il veut
pas voir un pervers narcissique
ce simple que c'est juste un trottoir le
crotoy oui c'est pour les chiens
variaient de 2 voilà non il n'y a pas de
définition des trottoirs et maintenant
crotoy et puis il ya aussi
le pervers avec intérêts ouverte et
alors ça c'est un des coups d'éclat
aussi attendait le pin ailleurs une
écolo vicieux
appuie d'ailleurs c'est un mari infidèle
aguerris avec un s installe
le pineau on ne dit pas je tripote mais
j'ai trois amis
mais c'est bien ça
un enjoliveur un ange livreur pardon
dans le livre libre heures c'est un
livreur qui est joli garçon
mais aussi des définitions des gens qui
se font chier ont souvent un air
constipé
c'est tellement fin pour moi c'est vous
êtes amusé à face a duré un an avec
notre ami gb rejoint wade journalistes
on a mis un an
c'est lui qui a eu l'idée d'art je le
remercierai jamais assez un an à
s'amuser à dire là on prend ce mot là si
on transforme ça donnerait quoi comme
définition donc non mais t'es super et
vous du coup on a trouvé à prendre a été
dans d'autres rubriques autres et on a
aussi trouvé le féminin et le masculin
de certains nous risquons à créer des
histoires on a fait des métaphores on a
créé des fausses d'épitaphe
l'épitaphe de
bernard henri lévy c'est admirer ma
pierre dombasle
bon voilà c'est d'être idiot la langue
fon dir-est bouge il ya des chances
aussi que vous réécrivez voilà allô
maman bio bio quand tu m'as fait je suis
pas bio donc c'est l'actualité il ya
comment se faire que depuis un 2e sur
sur l'air de
sonic
c'était très amusant et est ce que je
dis c'est vrai que on peut jouer sujet
soit citée à qena qui peut prendre le
livre et qui dit qu'est ce que c'est
quoi la définition de ça on réfléchit
d'ailleurs à faire un jeu parce qu'on
s'est rendu compte que les familles qui
récupère et le bouquin quand je faisais
des dédicaces dans toute la france avec
mes enfants on leur pose des questions
et puis on commença donc on réfléchit on
sous quel format je ne sais pas mais en
tout cas ça donne lieu à beaucoup
d'imagination que l'image est ce que les
noms interne est friand légitimus
légitime mais je sais pas bourdon il a
tendance parfois
le bourdon et campons il a une tante je
sais pas c'est pas aussi vibratoire et
le cantique que ça mais c'est vrai que
moi abandonné je me suis posé la
question est-ce que je suis légitimement
ma place parce que j'étais un plutôt
quelqu'un de gt1 fait au départ les
autres je me tais comme j'étais timide
je me disais toujours qu'est ce que j'ai
le droit de jouer une femme qui m'a dit
non mais si tu es là c'est que si tu es
là si tu as eu un césar un molière c'est
que ça a tout numérique ça va essam a
déclenché un truc d'hambourg dont je
dirais plutôt bien ça tout le monde le
sait qu'il est plutôt un peu soupe au
lait bourdon c'est là que voilà et c'est
bourdon quoi et campan ben il ya une
espèce de timidité un respect des choses
mais bon ce sont c'est pas des défauts
qui sont très très désengageant mais
tout cas ce sont de très belles
personnes ouais je vous le confirme les
belles des dessins à belgrade 1 même si
bordeaux a un peu dérapé ya pas
longtemps là il a pas ce qu'il a dit une
phrase qui a un peu dérapé ce qui fait
que mais ce n'était pas intentionnel des
fois on est pris dans un espèce de
marasme médiatique mais c'est vrai que
ce sont alors on se ressemble bien tous
les trois on est vraiment on aime notre
métier passionnément trois frères on a
des choses à dire un peu ça alors on a
des choses à dire sur cette société qui
va de plus en plus mal alors que tout va
bien a priori c'est compliqué donc voilà
on se sent utile et nécessaire merci
beaucoup pascal légitimus giroud
assez monsieur patrice
[Musique]